bonsoir honneur aux aides au radeau
merci d'être avec nous en direct sur rt
france alors on l'a commenté un les
choses s'améliorent plus de saturation
il n'empêche ya toujours une
augmentation des décès alors qu'on se
profile vers le déconfinement quel est
l'état d'esprit des espagnols on imagine
qu'ils doivent être très éprouvés après
des semaines de confinement assez
stricte et un nombre de victimes
extrêmement important effectivement
c'est le cas l'espagne en sont éprouvés
parce que vous savez que le confinement
espagnol et le plus dur de tous les pays
européens à un exemple ce n'est qu'à
partir dès dimanche que les enfants
espagnols vont pouvoir sortir au moins
une heure dans la rue et pas plus loin
d'un kilomètre comme en france ça fait
cinq semaines
quel est son fond espagnols sont
confinés son savoir le droit de sortir
ni une seule fois dans la rue donc mais
même avec cette chiffre-là les espagnols
dos un sondage apparu il y a quelques
jours s'est dit c'est que 73 % étaient
pour le prolongement du confinement est
pourquoi tout simplement parce que vous
l'avez dit aujourd'hui ses vingt-deux
mille morts ou encore en espagne
aujourd'hui c'est plus de 200000
personnes contaminées aujourd'hui c'est
encore plus des 4600 contamination par
jour le sait spagnol souhaite pouvoir
finir avec le confinement mais en même
temps ils voient que les chiffres font
froid dans le dos donc d'un côté oui il
faudrait commencer à sortir parce que
les pays est fortement touché l'économie
espagnole est fortement touchée
d'ailleurs on commence à se poser la
question comment est-ce qu'on va s'en
sortir si on n'a pas les aides des
autres pays européens
mais pour l'instant les espagnols et
c'est tout simplement des survivre si
vous permettez cette expression et d
essayer d'enrayer cette pandémie que qu
on vous l'avait dit a fait plus de 22
mille morts déjà en espagne à la juan
jose haedo radio vous nous parliez du
bilan qui effectivement très important
il n'empêche que la presse se fait écho
du fait que l'essentiel des décès ne
figurerait pas dans les statistiques
officielles a lancé le cas aussi dans
d'autres pays
royaume uni c'est la même chose la
france pareil j'ai toujours cette
suspicion entre le bilan officiel est le
vrai bilan pour comprendre d'ailleurs ce
qui a pu se passer en espagne la justice
a ouvert semble-t-il 86 enquête
préliminaire expliquez nous
effectivement il ya eu de son enquête
préliminaire ouverte par la justice
notamment par rapport aux à l'équivalent
des ehpad en france pour comprendre
comment il est possible qu'il y ait eu
au tandem des ddc et qu'on ait pas su
qu'on ne laissait pas annoncé quand il
quand il le fallait vous savez qui est
par exemple les morts dont les ehpad
c'est surtout l'armé quand elle a été
déployée qui les a découverts pour la
pour la pour la plupart il y à quelques
cm il ya près d'un deuxième ligne des
régions espagnoles a dû reconnaître
qu'il y avait certainement plus de 3000
morts en plus de ce qui était annoncé et
la réalité est qu'aujourd'hui le
gouvernement espagnol est fortement
contestée les espagnols considèrent que
la crise est assez mal géré les chiffres
montrent que 22 villes mort ce n'est pas
avoir bien géré et c'est de cette crise
vous savez et les espagnols aussi ses
poses la question sur le pourcentage par
exemple des personnels sanitaires qui
est contaminée l'espagne à ce triste
record seul pays d'europe où il ya le
plus d personnel sanitaire médecins
infirmiers aides soignants contaminés
par les coronavirus plus des 25000
personnes le sont aujourd'hui
et effectivement la justice espagnole
donc a été saisie par rapport au décès
dont les étapes mais aussi par rapport
aux associations des médecins par
exemple qui ont déposé plainte
par contre le gouvernement espagnol est
contre le président espagnol par
négligence juste un chiffre il faut
savoir que le gouvernement espagnol a
acheté plusieurs millions des masques
mais récemment il a dû rendre 700 mille
masques qui a été distribué aux
personnels soignants parce que ces
masques n'était pas bonne et d'été et
des masques qui ne correspondaient pas
aux standards et qui ont permis par
exemple quand je vous disais la
contamination de personnel soignant
donc aujourd'hui le gouvernement est
contestée parce qu'il n'a pas su gérer
combinables convenablement
cette crise est maintenant certainement
dans quelques semaines dans quelques
mois plus tôt la justice aura assez
prononcé d'un côté sur le nombre de
morts et qui est revue à laver
systématiquement par les gouvernements
compensée par les gouvernements
autonomes que les décès déclarés dans
les mairies sont des plus en plus
importante les chiffres ne cadre pas
calé dans ce contexte le moral au sein
de la population à ce que ceux des
confinement qui se profile un le 9 mai
d'ailleurs et des industries qui ont
déjà ouvertes en espagne est ce que
c'est une perspective quand même dû qui
met du baume au coeur même si vous
l'avez dit certains espagnols demandent
à rester à 1 confiné effectivement la
date est pour l'instant est celle du 9
mai puisque l'état d'urgence a été donc
que prolonger jusqu'à cette date du 9
mai par la suite de toute façon le
gouvernement et son président a déjà
annoncé que le confinement on va se
faire comme en france on voit à peu près
dé façon progressive
mais par contre il n'a pas encore dit
comment ça va se faire directement on se
pose la question du nombre de masques
soufis sont pour que les gens puissent
sortir dans la rue on se pose la
question des tests
est ce qu'on aura cédé test pour pouvoir
tester et les espagnols qui vont sortir
on sait par contre effectivement déjà
qu'elle accompagne touristique d'été et
est complètement ratée d'ailleurs le
gouvernement va maintenir au moins
jusqu'à la mi-juin pour l'instant les
frontières espagnoles ferme m il est
très probable effectivement qu'elle soit
beaucoup plus retarder l'ouverture des
ces et frontière espagnole donc il y a
l'ovi de pouvoir commencer à sortir mais
en même temps les espagnols ont aussi la
peur au ventre
dd se dire qu'est ce chiffre des
vingt-deux mille morts pourrait croître
énormément
si le contenu et des confits demande
n'était pas fait correctement et donc
devant c'était équation il préférerait
quand je vous disais dans un récent
sondage continuer un peu plus confiné
mais s'assurer que le de confinement
n'apportera pas plus de morts merci
beaucoup ron rosé dorado journalistes
espagnols d'avoir été avec nous
en direct sur rt france pour nous parler
de la situation donc en espagne